je n'aime pas les religions et je n'aime
pas l'islam existe je ne l'aime pas je
ne l'aime pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je vous ai connu vous en aviez que
deux ah oui mais là maintenant il y a
tous les bras coté et le M de l'autre je
m'en souviens c'était déjà le M c'est
une première connerie pourquoi
dès que j'ai commencé à 18 ans à faire
mon prêtage en fait je réfléchissais
même pas je dis j'allais chez le
tatoueur je vois des dessins au mur déjà
tu veux bien faire ça ah je veux bien
inspiration plutôt que de faire des
beaux trucs si j'ai juste fait du
remplissage en noir parce que je voulais
les bras remplis le plus vite possible
donc ce bras là c'est vraiment le bras
de mes 17 18 19 ans et c'est une
catastrophe je le déteste alors ce qui
est vrai c'est que malheureusement il
faut le dire alors attention c'est le
tatouage vieillit pas très très mal et
c'est vrai que la tête d'aigle même sur
Johnny à la
finale
Johnny mais c'est vrai que ça peut faire
un peu quand on écoute tu as les cheveux
un peu blanc en boîte de nuit et tu
arrêtes tu fais un peu vieux quoi ça moi
je voulais faire un tatouage à maman et
puis c'est vrai que vous me connaissez
je j'ai un petit peu de je suis un petit
peu égocentrique je m'aime bien je vais
trouver plutôt beau et je me suis dit
est-ce qu'on est pas en train de une
bâche sur une Ferrari
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai tu vois
c'est comme si t'es beau Robbie Williams
ça votre avis qu'est-ce qui s'est fait
tatouer qu'est-ce qu'il aurait pu faire
un petit peu du sens de la répartie un
ballon de l'humour que vous êtes tu vois
non en l'occurrence qu'est-ce qu'il a je
suis même pas vous dire ah si il a un
revie tattoo il a ah oui ah oui voilà et
voyez il a fait il y a une erreur il a
mis chacun à ses goûts il voulait créer
en français c'est chacun ses goûts le
tatouage anus du chat sur le nombril de
qui ça c'est qui ça
ah oui
c'est mon dieu
c'est un très gros anus
la mâchoire lui dit puis il a glissé en
chaussettes je suis dans son appartement
il est tombé sur un escalier il s'est
cassé la mâchoire et quand on lui a
refait et ben il a fallu qu'il travaille
les muscles de la mâchoire et du coup ça
a déformé sa mâchoire quand on corps bon
ça il dit que c'est pour un film je vous
dis ça c'est piqûre camping personne
comme ça mais c'est vrai que voilà
Monsieur
des années 70 exactement à ça donc les
muscles ont quand même lui accorder ça
oui le fait que voilà par contre le
menton tu parles de la chute alors lui
c'est déjà c'est pas un escalier c'est
une petite fontaine en pierre qu'il a
chez lui
et apparemment ces fans qui sont bien
renseignés parce qu'ils le suivent très
bien parlent plutôt d'hormones qu'il
aurait tellement pris quand on prend à
ce stade ça fait gonfler la mâchoire
bien sûr les élastiques
est connu pour cette écharpe et
plusieurs fois sur les plateaux télé
notamment lors de ces années on n'est
pas couché aux côtés d'Eric Zemmour
portez des pantalons en lambeau et une
robe que ça fait de vous un rebelle il
n'est pas le seul à avoir été boycoté
par certains médias comme l'actrice
Véronique jeunesse depuis ses prises de
position sur la guerre en Ukraine ou
vis-à-vis du vaccin s'est attiré les
foudres vous avez dit Madame et ça
Guillaume excuse-moi on n'a pas le droit
c'est être islamophobe c'est d'avoir
peur je suis islamophobie beaucoup de
Français mais oui
je comprendrais que si islamophobe
sur les mots c'est ce que j'ai laissé
votre fracturer la société vous savez
très bien vous savez très bien comment
dire peur alors oui effectivement je
suis islamophobe parce que j'ai peur
alors d'abord je vais me faire remarquer
que sémantiquement islamophobie ça parle
de l'islam et pas des musulmans d'accord
donc effectivement je n'aime pas les
religions et je n'aime pas l'islam j'ai
le droit et vous aviez ajouté et vous
aviez ajouté je parle évidemment des
intégristes pour ceux qui veulent la
différence elle existe
pas je ne l'aime pas ensuite il y a
l'affaire Zemmour moi je calcule pas
est-ce que c'est bon pour ma carrière
est-ce que c'est pas bon pour ma
carrière il est pas question que je
renie un ami pour quelques raisons que
ce soit c'est un ami de longue date
c'est un ami que j'espère que nous
resterons
je l'ai pas souvent vas-y quand même
il y a des tas de choses avec lesquelles
je ne suis pas d'accord je ne suis pas
d'accord sur le dossier russe pas plus
que je ne suis d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit puisque vous êtes en pleinement
et que je vous ai entendu dire derrière
j'y suis allé par curiosité je vous en
veux pas chacun votre qui veut mais
derrière vous savez qu'à partir du
moment où vous êtes dans cette niche là
vous allez de toute manière vous mettre
une partie de l'opinion ou une partie
des dirigeants ados vous le savez ça
j'ai un ami de longue date qui se porte
candidat à la présidentielle ça arrive
pas tous les jours non il fait il fait
un meeting qui était l'événement du
moment j'ai jamais connu une ambiance
pareille c'était cerné de flics il y
avait 10 000 personnes l'ambiance de
stade de football il me semble que ma
place d'amis et ma place de journaliste
non et dans ce ben si moi je vous le dis
on a peut-être pas on a peut-être pas la
même conception du journaliste surtout
que vous vous ne l'êtes pas et moi je le
suis donc c'est peut-être ça qui nous
différencie aussi et je vous dis
simplement que en tant qu'ami et en tant
que journaliste ma place était là
Laurent Kerusore on avait déjà reçu ici
voilà qui jouait Thomas merci dans Plus
Belle La Vie et bien il a poussé un gros
coup de gueule et il a dit aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas y retourner je n'y arrive
pas même l'année dernière il a fini par
se rendre par s'y rendre pour pour
apporter avec lui un bout un bout du
plateau pour vous savez qu'il y avait la
grande le grand prime time mais là il
met les amours je suis retourné au
studio aujourd'hui vous allez trouver
cette règle mais j'ai donc ramené la
tombe de Roland la tire tombale de la
fille merci bah oui mais pardon et
regardez ce qui rajoute surtout c'est là
où vous me direz ce que vous en pensez
je crois que je me suis je me suis
grillé en acceptant le rôle de Thomas
donc dans Plus belle la vie pendant des
années je pense que toute ma vie me
considère comme Thomas donc vous vous
donc vous voyez un chômeur devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est horrible des 18
prochaines années vont être horribles je
vais bouffer des pâtes à tes enfants
c'est pas grave c'est comme cela on ne
veut pas de moi car je suis Thomas tant
pis pour eux ou peut-être pas je suis
[ __ ] tout simplement donc voilà voilà ce
qu'il dit il dit qu'il a accepté un rôle
d'homosexuel en plus belle la vie et que
maintenant et bien on ne portera plus
jamais à lui pour autre chose parce
qu'il est trop marqué une fois que tu es
cantonais un personnage pendant 18 ans
mais c'est vrai que maintenant revenir
et lui changer de personnage et de nom
dans un dans tous les autres acteurs
déjà je trouve que Laurent kerusurier ça
fait 15 ans qui tient le même discours
donc oui il parle toujours de son
orientation sexuelle il parle toujours
du fait qu'il est cantonné à ça c'est
aussi ce qui fait qu'il y a un grand
rôle dans la dans la série sauf que il
faut aussi rappeler que dans Plus belle
la vie on a aussi compris des choix
difficiles à un moment notamment Sarah
Mortensen qui aujourd'hui cartonne sur
France 2 et elle est pas la seule à
avoir fait des un choix qui est qui est
risqué il aurait pu le faire lui aussi
il a eu des propositions à une époque je
m'en souviens bien sûr et et voilà il a
peut-être jugé que le cachet le rôle
l'exposition qu'il avait dans Plus belle
la vie était plus importante à ce
moment-là c'est horrible deux fois c'est
horrible on va manger des patates ça va
être l'enfer pendant encore 18 ans avec
les enfants enfin il y a un truc
non mais il y a non seulement une
exagération puis en plus la corrélation
avec son homosexualité
[Musique]
personne
j'espère que Mégane est l'ont vu quand
même
c'est ça qui est incroyable quand on a
l'abandon ancien enfin on découvre les
premières images de ce truc il y a 6
épisodes donc on se demande tout ce
qu'il va y avoir les images sont dingues
enfin il y a des images très très fortes
il y a des images de bonheur bien sûr on
sent que Netflix a pas payé des millions
de dollars pour entendre juste on s'aime
on est heureux on est d'accord on va y
avoir quelque chose qu'est-ce qui est
exactement personne ne le sait et
surtout est-ce qu'ils ont voulu modifier
leur propos suite à la mort de la reine
et à l'accession trône de Charles III
toute la question c'est de savoir à quel
point ça peut être dommageable pour la
monarchie pour Charles III en fait le
mois de décembre chez Windsor je sais
pas si vous avez votre pop-corn mais ça
va être dingue si vous avez fini the
crown ou si vous avez pas fini
finissez-le parce que là ça va être le
nouveau the crown et le 10 janvier en
plus il y a les mémoires d'Harry donc je
pense que Noël va pas être terrible à
Sandrine